here at the swimming club in maidenhead
is where olympic champion tom dean
showed his potential from the age of 8
until 18
he trained with coach paul lloyd he says
tom has long been a role model to the
squad
his tokyo success will just make that
influence stronger
it won't just be our club it'll be
swimming in this area
and probably swimming around the whole
country you know the guys in scotland
will probably be a little bit more
inspired by duncan scott the guys in the
midlands will be certainly inspired by
lmpd
but it's that local connection isn't it
but for our swimmers to see tom in the
flesh
so he's no longer some mysterious
demigod he's a human being
just makes it more real to our
youngsters that they can follow that
trajectory too if they apply themselves
what's really impacted british swimming
over the last 20 years
has been funding coaches tell me that
it's the investment from the national
lottery
that's taken the sport to another level
and the rewards can be felt at
grassroots
this elite swim squad in wales prides
itself on being inclusive
thirteen-year-old megan willis has her
sights on a victory
at the paralympics it's a very big
commitment it takes up a lot of your
time
and you have to be very dedicated to
like do the sport
i'd say something i love to do and there
are sacrifices in it say like missing an
odd birthday party or missing out on
something but it's all worth it
for the fun of it and the enjoyment of
it
as future generations of swimmers watch
history being made in tokyo
a former olympian credits the success to
previous games
as a result of the london 2012 legacy we
were given
great facilities um i just think what
london did
we're sort of seeing the results now it
did inspire a generation and
it was so special and i think it's
amazing that when
not just seeing and making olympics in
london but
the legacy is living on
and it's hoped the legacy left by tokyo
will be
even more medals for team gb in the
years to come
charlotte lomas sky news